[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants
qu'avez vous fait de beaux aujourd'hui
ouhlala ah mais vous avez tous été très
occupé mirabel et son frère petit louis
eux sont en train d'arroser les fleurs
de leur maison ils ont bien raison
comme ça elle pousseront et seront plus
belle je veux usées des patrons oui
nounours mais ne fait pas de bêtise
patron vous pouvez compter sur moi
et hop la pop hip hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop encore un
peu tôt
voilà tu sais mirabel colombes à manger
tout ça c'est là le gentil c'est très
bon là ça là ça fait grandir
alors on arrose les fleurs en effet nous
maintenons fait jouer bonjour bonjour
nov
il nous montre un jeu nouveau oui aj
qu'on connaît pas s'ils ont joué à
cache-cache koné a alors j'ai pas
beaucoup d'imagination
ben non alors patron s'il vous plaît à
quoi on pourrait bien jouer si vous le
voulez bien nous allons jouer à pigeon
vole gros ours va vous dire des noms
d'objets ou d'animaux et vous devez
lever le doigt uniquement lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un nom d'animal ou d'un objet
qui peut voler et ceux qui se trompent
devront faire un gage d'accord patron
merci allongé rome avant dijon val file
vole plus une valve table veulent t'ils
oui tu t'es trompé
le canari val marmite vos mains oui tu
as lever le doigt
bon ça vole collombat vol là alors vous
n'êtes pas fort que vous n'avez pas
lever le doigt
pauvre petit colin
à cette petite cage elle sourit pas
beaucoup ça c'est vrai mme amal dit
qu'il faut la ramener à la campagne avec
d'autres oiseaux qu'elle sera beaucoup
plus heureuse va l'emmener mais c'est
une excellente idée
elle sera plus heureux pas d'accord on
l'emmène à la campagne tu sais à présent
les enfants vous devez payer votre gages
et puis allez sagement au dodo obtient
une belle chanson d'amour ou oui c'est
ça ma chanson moi c'est la fin
[Musique]
non
amis il s'en va tout seul et nous y
allons aussi 2010
je n'en sais rien au gel autant dire
[Musique]
il nous dira fermez vos yeux et d'hommes
et tous les deux nous sommes bien dans
notre ligue
sauf nous fouette un bon ami sacko ce
mois
plaisir vernis merci mes deux petits
amis au revoir votre chanson est très
très belle année neuf bonnes huiles les
enfants
[Musique]
alors les enfants notre jeu vous a plu
oui et bien maintenant embrasser bien
fort vos parents est allé sagement vous
coucher à te voilà gros ours s'était
bien amusé auront oui pas trop peu ils
vont chanter une très belle chanson en
avant nos sources
venus les enfants fait de très beaux
rêves
bonne nuit
[Musique]
e